this is like my fourth overall and it
still feels like
the very first time foreigner had it
right it feels like the first time
every time i'm so excited i love i love
all the albums in this category
i know the grammy's gonna be very
different this year and it's gonna
probably be all virtual but
have you prepared an ex an acceptance
speech
i haven't but i've thought about some
scenarios i thought what if we get
all of us gals that are in that category
together to watch the grammys together
i don't know that that's possible i
talked to karen fairchild okay from
a little big town and she was totally on
board when i asked miranda
i said do you think we can sit together
she said i don't think they'll let the
bad kids sit together
but now that it's all virtual i don't
know it's a possibility
[Music]
now best country album category is
dominated by women right now
you know it's a beautiful thing yet
we're still talking about the fact that
a lot of women
are not being played on radio how do you
feel about that like
do you think change will happen i'm
actually wondering how many grammy
nominations it takes to get my songs
played on the radio
is it four do we know is it for anybody
i think the changes that need to happen
are happening we just have to remember
not to be bitter and when you finally
get played on the radio just
just accept that with love but use humor
when you have to because you're gonna
have to
first of all congratulations on your
grammy nominations for best country
album and best country solo performance
how did you react when you heard that
news galatian
honestly you're not gonna lie it was one
of those
um it was definitely the best day of
2020 for me
i have to ask have you already written
out your acceptance speech yet
i haven't maybe you know i've never won
i've been nominated
this is my eighth nomination which is
amazing maybe i should write out a
speech maybe that might change my luck
[Music]
your album life is a record what did you
want to say with these songs
you know between my last record big day
in a small town
and your life is a record i went through
a lot of changes professionally and
[Music]
personally
i went through a breakup of a long
relationship and
that made its way into these songs
without me realizing that's what was
happening
there was a lot of change and i think
this record um reflects that